and of course joshua bassett was the
rumored love interest behind olivia's
smash hit driver's license now the star
is opening up in people's latest issue
discussing the stress that was caused by
the release and the backlash
[Music]
i was like i need to go right now and so
i don't know what it was other than my
heart
it was just an innate knowing i was like
i need help i need help right now so i
called them and i went to the hospital
and they were like you were right i mean
i you know i mentioned this before but
they were like if you hadn't checked in
within 12 hours
you would have been found in your
apartment the 21 year old was diagnosed
with septic shock and spent nine days in
hospital when i got out of the hospital
was even more depressed and even more
stressed um you would think that an
experience like that would be like oh i
need to enjoy my life and everything's
great i think it made me realize like
just how much of my life i was missing
and i think i felt so
hopeless joshua also opens up about the
sexual abuse trauma he endured as a
child but tells people magazine he is
now moving on with a positive outlook i
feel like i've had an attitude for most
of my life of like whatever's happening
to me right now is teaching me
so i think in general i've always held
that mentality so i might not have
thought those conscious thoughts last
year but i think there was there was a
general knowing of like whatever's
happening is is to strengthen
me and for the betterment of me joshua
says while he wasn't planning on coming
out last year now he feels so liberated
everyone my whole life has told me my
sexuality like both ends i've been told
my whole life you're very gay or you're
not gay or
everything between and it's like
why is this ending your business why do
you feel you need to tell me and also
like what does it matter
[Applause]